what's going on everybody Ian hardits
here on behalf of PFF welcome to another
week of BR fantasy bye weeks here it's
week six it's always a great day to be
great though before we get into today's
topic I want to go through some key
injury news from around the NFL and
we're always having more injuries to
deal with unfortunately with that said
Saints wide receiver room remains all
kinds of banged up right now Michael
Thomas we heard last Sunday from ESPN's
Adam schefter that he had a good chance
of shooting up this week yet to return
to practice though with that foot injury
also so Jarvis Landry on the sideline
with the ankle injury but Chris alave
did get back to a limited practice
despite having that scary concussion
last week so I would think with the new
NFL concussion protocol rules going in
that olave again after that nasty injury
he had last week won't be out there but
based on the practice participation he
might actually have the best chance of
all these Saints wide receivers looking
at Dallas Dak Prescott for the first
time since messing up his right thumb
back at practice in a limited fashion
still tentatively expecting Cooper rush
to be under Center but this might
actually be the final week we see the
ginger Jesus that is ready to go by week
seven we do have Damon Harris still very
much limited with that hamstring injury
he is considered week to week and that
means it is finally ramondre Stevenson
rb1 season might have taken you know
four or five different things to go his
way to happen but they happen so here we
are fire up remandre Stevenson and fan
slams of all shapes and sizes God note
that Rashad Bay was still not practicing
with that foot injury it's bye weeks
it's I get it it's tough times right now
if you need a wide receiver good chance
Devin Duvernay is still on your waiver
wire also note that Jonathan Taylor back
at practice is by dealing with that
ankle injury expecting him to be good to
go they did have an extra long week to
get him ready after obviously missing
last week's Thursday night atrocity
against the Broncos please Jonathan
Taylor for all of us that have to watch
Colts games every week get back there
start doing your thing again and finally
everyone this Cardinals backfield go get
you know Benjamin if you yeah if he's
available on your waiver wire keep
watching please we always enjoy having
you here but then go get Eno Benjamin
because he is setting up to be a fan
really feature back in Arizona this week
James Connor doubtful with the rib
injury and Daryl Williams already rolled
out with a knee injury so
I understand this Arizona backfield look
this whole offense really other than
Marquis Brown and Kyla Murray to an
extent we haven't seen consistent
high-end performances but there's only a
handful of coaches really willing to
give their overall rb1 a true Workhorse
role Arizona and Cliff Kingsbury has
been one of them over the years so make
sure you keep keep an eye on all these
injuries throughout the week they're
always updating and you can always check
out the PFF fantasy football podcast on
Friday where I'll get you covered with
all those fantasy relevant injuries each
and every week but with that said
everyone let's get things started this
is BR Fantasy Live presented by State
Farm and we got a great show for you
today Panic or relax is the theme of the
show look we've we all have a player on
our fantasy teams that we're currently
dealing with this it's only been five
weeks we drafted them for a reason but
so far that reason has not come to
fruition do we Panic or do we relax I'm
here to help you find out and we have
eight different players that to go
through and determine just that so
starting things off with Los Angeles
Rams quarterback Matthew Stafford guys
just the qb23 so far this season not
exactly what we were hoping for when he
really again was being prioritized well
ahead of some guys like Jared Goff you
know Smith Carson Wentz guys that are
actually giving us more fantasy points
right now than what we got out of
Stafford so with Stafford it has been
brutal guys again qb23 overall but on a
weekly basis qb30 qb10 qb29 qb29 and
most recently qb15 so the volume has
actually been there over the last two
weeks only Brady and Matthew Stafford
have triple digit drop back so the hope
is that the Sean McVeigh offense can't
stay this bad for this long guys because
even the worst version of the Jared Goff
Rams offense really wasn't this bad if
you look at the Rams ranks just an
overall scoring under Sean McVay since
2017 first second 11th 22nd in the back
golf year and then seventh last season
so the bigger concern I think for staff
from this offense is just
the lack of anywhere to go with the ball
if it's not being thrown the Cooper
copper Tyler Higby at this point we'll
talk about Alan Robinson a little bit
more in a bit spoiler right there but so
far guys this Rams offense 31st in PFF
pass blocking grade and 31st in rushing
so yeah they're 28th and passing
Stafford hasn't exactly been helping
things single lowest rate of catchable
deep balls in the entire league and you
know with that in mind guys we got our
Panic meter to show you all
[Music]
thank you
I am panicking I am not relaxing we are
in the red for a reason here this
offense looks completely broken and I'm
not so sure someone like van Jefferson
or Odo Beckham coming off of the you
know coming off an ACL tear even if he
does resign with the Los Angeles Rams
are going to be enough to be able to fix
this unit again it's not just on
Stafford it's on the entire offensive
line the Run game and according to Sean
McVay as well for continuing to be
unable to get this offense to literally
just be average because that's the
problem here it's not that Stafford and
Company relative the expectations are
not meeting them it's that Stafford and
Company are literally a bottom five
offense in the NFL right now so I don't
think Stafford will be completely
unusable down the stretch but it's time
to adjust your expectations and really
start treating Stafford far more as a
match up the pendant qb2 than someone
that needs to be started each and every
week love all you guys in the chat with
us we'll continue to get to all your
questions throughout Today's Show
starting off with Jake Winters thoughts
on DeAndre Hopkins when he returns so
what the really interesting part is
going to be for this in my opinion is
Rondell Moore so Hopkins first week he's
back get him back in the starting
lineups you know he's been staring at us
for quite some time you know I sent out
a tweet on Monday from the office where
you know his Creed walking up behind Jim
and just giving him the shoulder rub one
more week that's been Hopkins on our
fantasy bench here uh just waiting to
get back in there so I'm excited about
Hopkins I think some of his decline last
year has been overstated it was just a
matter of Kyla Murray really spreading
the ball around so having Hollywood
Brown in the offense yes there only is
one ball to go around but come on guys
it's DeAndre Hopkins they paid him all
that money for a reason he is going to
be involved but the real question is
going to be will it be Hopkins on one
side Hollywood Brown on the other and
Rondell Moore in the slot or are they
going to do what they did last year and
keep Rondo more off the field in favor
of old man AJ Green so we'll worry about
that next week this week though guys if
you need a wide receiver Rondell Moore
set up brilliantly in the slot against
the Seahawks defense that has been
bottom five in any metric you want to
look at against slot receivers from
Mickey W should I start Hill this week
hey man it depends it's one of those
things where hey I get it with tasteum
it's really hard to actually rank more
than 10 or 12 tight ends ahead of the
guy because when you start looking past
you know 10 or 11 tight ends all of a
sudden you're looking at guys that yeah
they're going to have more snaps and
tase them but tasem is kind of breaking
the mold of everything we've thought
we've known about fantasy tight ends
because his snaps aren't up there but
when he is on the field he's getting the
football so for me I have taysom Hill
ranked as my overall tight end 14 this
week I'll play take some hell ahead of
guys like Dalton Schultz Cole commit
Tyler Conklin with that said you know
Hayden Hurst Hunter Henry Gerald Everett
I am still going to lean towards those
guys a bit more I don't think taysom
Hill is going to be ripping off 60-yard
touchdown runs every single week as
impressive as that week five performance
was
from James Dolan you know Benjamin isn't
going to last long term though you're
not wrong man but it's this week and hey
it's a week to week League out here and
we gotta try to win them as much as we
can so with James Connor again likely
sidelined for at least this week if not
a few more Daryl Williams already rolled
out it is you know Benjamin top 15 top
20 running back season at least for week
six so I hear you I mean if you are a
stack team and like you're just not
going to be starting Eno anyway you
don't need to pick him up I would go
look at guys like Rashad white Jalen
Warren uh you know these true handcuffs
that really have longer term potential
if things break their way but still a
good position if you again need a flex
need a starting running back you know
Benjamin can be that guy for you here at
least in week six if not a little bit
beyond all right guys now the second
quarterback that's been disappointed now
we gotta decide if we are panicking or
relaxing gonna be Denver Broncos own
Russell Wilson so far just the QB 18
after five weeks of action he did get us
a nice little three touchdown
performance in week four he finished as
the overall QB for that week otherwise
though 3 finishes outside the top 20
signal callers over the past four weeks
and there's been a variety of problems
here there's 14.6 rushing yards per game
second lowest Mark of his career the
accuracy has been off every area of the
field short intermediate and deep he's
been ranking outside the top 20
quarterbacks in each and there's also
the reality that he's hurt he's getting
the injection in his shoulder they're
calling it a similar injury as to what
Dak Prescott had to deal with last year
and yeah Dak was able to overcome a lot
of that with volume but don't forget
guys as impressive as that week one game
was for Dak last year against Tampa Bay
the home for over 400 yards and all that
serious questions about that arm
strength if he could be that same guy so
Russell Wilson we've all seen his you
know physical limitations before in
terms of his height and being able to
see over the line and all that so if you
do take away his ability to throw those
patented Moon balls down field I think
it does make more sense why he has been
struggling enough already and also guys
it's been five weeks with Nathaniel
Hackett Denver Broncos brand new group
of wide receivers so a lot of variables
going on and with that we once again go
to our Panic meter
[Music]
sound scares me every time we're going
to be in Orange here I'm not completely
freaking out on the you know let's ride
experience just yet certainly hasn't
been good my main thought here at
Russell Wilson is it's not so much an
investment in Rust being this Elite
quarterback anymore we just need him to
be average not the atrocity that he has
largely been through the first five
weeks of the Season we still have Sutton
Judy KJ Handler's health is improving
they're getting their rookie tight end
who's their best receiving tight end
Greg dolch is coming off of ir and based
on what we saw last week okay A little
bit of juice from Melbourne Gordon but
just not having Javonte Williams I would
not be surprised if the Broncos are just
forced basically in the shootout happy
AFC West and with you know again not
having the resources to really run the
ball Russell Wilson might have enough
Elite volume to make up for his lack of
efficiency but again he needs a lot of
things to go his way so I will say Russ
and Stafford similar sentiment where I
don't think they're completely unusable
the rest of the year but the days of
looking at your lineup and you got
Russell Wilson in the qb1 spot and just
completely disregarding the matchup I do
believe those are over so hey find a
second quarterback on the wager wire
don't be afraid to go match up by
match-up out there then it's completely
Panic again I still think there's enough
talent in this Broncos offense two gifts
and Spike weeks all the way around
clearly though the early returns not
promising and expecting this to be the
sort of top 10 offense a lot of us were
hoping they could be when this trade
happened in the first place
from Dem boys in the chat Danny dimes or
Jameis Winston for half PPR so Jameis is
looking like he's gonna be back there
he's still playing with the four
fractures in his back but the man's
gonna tough it out if we can get even
like two of these wide receivers back
for Jameis I will be fine going to him
otherwise I think it's going to be an
offensive effort just completely
centered around run the ball with Alvin
Kamara and Mark Ingram that's what it
was last year before they got these
receivers the same for the single most
run heavy offense in the NFL uh when
Jameis Winston was under Center in weeks
one through six last season so Daniel
dimes is actually you know it's funny we
call him Danny dimes but the actual
reason we want to play him is because of
his action is because of his legs so
fifth highest rushing Pace on the season
right now in terms of total attempts so
we'll talk a little about a little more
about Daniel Jones as a potential week
seven guy you can get by uh but I would
take James if one or two of Chris olave
Jarvis Landry and Michael Thomas are
able to suit up this week
from D boom Russell Wilson or Geno Smith
this week what a time to be alive guys
like can you imagine even asking this
question a month ago but it's a very
reasonable question with Geno Smith just
completely dominating out there I don't
know how many more weeks do you know
Smith needs to actually post you know
top 10 top five quarterback numbers
before we just kind of have to look at
ourselves and go well yeah I guess he is
a top 10 quarterback in the year 2022 so
I am going to give Geno Smith the nod
right here and this one is more so based
on what I talked about the matchup it's
not that I'm going to have Gino over
Russ every single week the rest of the
season but when we look at Geno this
week in a potential past happy shootout
with the Arizona Cardinals defense that
hasn't shown a great ability to slow
down many passing attacks this season I
will take that over Russ's you know trip
against Duran Duran James and Company in
Los Angeles and from campus what do you
think about George Kittle should I keep
him that's actually a great transition
cam because George Kittle actually is
our next player we're going to talk
about whether we should be relaxing or
panicking here and guys I really do
think this could be the week for George
Kittle so a couple reasons here why when
we see the Falcons we all know their
best quarterback AJ Terrell he's
actually been traveling a lot more this
year he's been following number one
receiver all over the field week after
week after week generally doing a pretty
good job Michael Thomas had two nice
contested catch touchdowns in week one
but Amari Cooper came up on the losing
side of things a couple weeks ago and
just in general AJ Terrell even if guys
are able to win okay it's one of those
things where you know great offense
can't beat great defense in the NFL just
like it does in basketball still not an
easy matchup with AJ Terrell but what
we've seen consistently is the other top
receiver uh actually start balling out
away from AJ Terrell so uh Jarvis Landry
and week one one for over 100 yards
Tyler Lockett had nine catches for 76
yards thousand people Jalen's Chris
Godwin the list goes on and on and while
it could be Debo Samuel this week either
Debo or Kittle is going to blow the heck
up and I am going to lean towards Kittle
because this Falcons defense just has
not shown they can slow down tight ends
all season long bottom three defense and
targets receptions and receiving yards
is allowed to receiving tight ends yeah
guys I'm not too worried let's go with
the Panic meter and show you guys not
how worried I am
[Music]
it's green we're good I am not concerned
about George Kittle I believe this will
be the eruption week where we're all
going to be happy we drafted George
Kittle and the fifth round in the first
place so I get it it hasn't been ideal
we haven't found the end zone yet but
you got to remember guys he was injured
to start the year the left tackle jokes
are being overblown I mean he's still
running around over 80 percent of Jimmy
G's dropbacks on a weekly basis this is
an offense that let's face it they had
Jimmy G coming back from a shoulder
injury they started the season with Trey
Lance like only as of last week they
actually leap out of the bottom five
offenses in terms of their point scored
this year so far better days to come for
George Kittle Brandon ayok the whole
Collective offense and again with this
mix matchup specifically George Kittle
should be in fantasy football lives of
all shapes and sizes
from Ryan Ribeiro Kittle you can start
left tackles guys that's what I'm saying
we pick like one or two plays where the
guy was blocking and we just assume
that's not it he ran a route on over 80
of Jimmy G's dropbacks last week that
happened that's the elite number we look
for with tight ends the guy really
leaves the field like it's not George
Kittle's fault he's an incredible
blocker and an incredible receiver I
maintain if the aliens invaded us
tomorrow and forced us to do you know a
Space Jam type thing for football George
Kittle would be our tight M1 Travis
Kelsey's awesome obviously Mark Andrews
is awesome but in terms of their ability
to block and catch I don't think there's
a better tight end on the planet than
George Kittle whenever he's healthy get
him in those fantasy lineups from
Zachary McLaurin should I panic
it's not great Curtis Samuel number one
wide receiver in Washington this year in
terms of Targets in terms of receptions
McLaren does still have the edge in
yards I will say for right now with
Jahan Dawson out of the picture is still
with that hamstring injury look I don't
think the Army Brown is going to be
getting two long touchdowns each and
every week I wouldn't be surprised that
Terry is that guy here moving forward
more weeks than not the good news for
Washington as much as we do see the bad
side of Carson Wentz and even though his
head coach uh owned head coach wants to
focus on that more than the good we have
at least seen a ceiling that really
hasn't been there under Taylor Heineken
some of these other quarterbacks they've
had in recent years so Carson Wentz
number one in the NFL and drop backs
that's a lot of volume to get out you
know some of the again rough patches
that we know we're going to see still
can be some goodness there for Terry and
Curtis Samuel especially when we have
guys like Johan Dawson and Logan Thomas
not factoring in as heavily as we
thought they might from etj Dawson Knox
is a droppable right yeah it's just a
matter of him being so banged up right
now I mean Quentin Morris last week
actually showed out pretty well he did
have the goal line fumble but he was
open for a touchdown and he's just an
athletic guy out there so they paid
Dawson Knox but as long as he's going to
be this banged up I'm not as convinced
he's going to have a featured role like
we're talking about the George Kittle
left tackles named Dawson Knox is the
one that wasn't able to even run a route
on more than 60 percent of Josh Allen's
dropbacks about a week so thoughts and
knocks not someone that needs to be on
fantasy rosters by any stretch of the
imagination
and from trapsy should I start Hayden
Hurst over Kyle Pitts not quite sad that
we got there and we're going to be
talking about Kyle Pitts more right now
let's get into it the tight end 23 on
the season there's some bad guys like
I'm not feeling good about this Falcons
offense at all which is wild because
somehow the Atlanta Falcons are the 10th
ranked offense in points per game this
season but the problem for me guys it's
not just pits like pits is fun we've
seen them out there making the most out
of his slim opportunities it seemed like
in the first few weeks of the year that
it was going to be Drake London instead
of Kyle Pitts well we've taken Kyle
Pitts out of the equation and now Drake
London isn't even giving us anything
three straight top 36 finishes for Drake
London to start the year back-to-back
games outside the top 50. and you want
to complain about routes I mean look at
the Atlanta Falcons olamide Zacchaeus
Was being used over Drake London uh last
week which is just so ridiculous but you
know we'll continue to focus here on
Kyle Pitts so again it comes down to the
volume and unfortunately I don't trust
Marcus Mariota B you know like a Ryan
Tannehill or someone that can actually
enable his receivers two big days on
limited volume this season only the
Falcons and the Bears have actually been
running the football on 50 or more of
their plays even you know when you
exclude non-go even when you exclude
excuse me garbage time situations so on
the season Marcus Mariota just four
touchdowns he's only averaging 185
passing yards per game those just aren't
the sort of numbers that we can be
expecting one let alone two consistent
high-end fantasy options out of so I
think you guys can tell about a tone of
my voice that things aren't looking
great let's see how exactly bad they are
with our Panic meter foreign
it's red yeah not good I didn't quite go
dark red because it says Kyle Pitts I
still believe in the talent and it does
seem like this hamstring injury isn't
going to be long term he's been back at
practice this week he says he expects to
play Kyle Pitts is still going to be
incredibly difficult to get out of your
top six top eight tight ends more weeks
than not it's just unfortunate that we
drafted the guy in the third round so uh
before the show you know we were just
talking a little bit about sunk cost
fallacy and not kind of having decisions
you made in August and early September
impact your decision making now so
that'd be the one big thing I want to
stress with Kyle Pitts yes it's fair to
just get your decisions in your just
overall expectations for Kyle Pitts
adjust those that's fine we have new
information we need to use that new
information but don't bench don't sell
low on Kyle Pitts just because you're
pissed off that you use a third round
pick on him a couple months ago he still
is an incredibly talented second year
tight end who should have some big days
ahead they're just going to be more
Boomer bus worthy because of the volume
and the efficiency involved in this
passing game similar sentiment there
with Drake London from Jazzy is tomorrow
Chase going to pick it up I really do
think so man it's Jamar Chase his volume
really has still been fine unfortunately
we've seen Joe burrow in this passing
game not have the same Success With The
Deep ball as a rookie Joe burrow and
Company where the League's basically
worst passing attack when trying to
throw 20 plus yards downfield last
season anyone's idea of a top five unit
I think we all kind of assumed that was
what happened when you add Jamar chase
the equation this year they've kind of
regressed to more of a middle of the
pack group so I do think we'll see some
bigger days out there as much as the
Zach Taylor experience you know hasn't
exactly been great on a weekly basis
with getting him going we are still
talking about a guy fresh off one of the
most impressive rookie Seasons at the
position in NFL history the volumes
there I really don't think tomorrow
Chase overnight became bad at football
continuing to treat him has a weekly top
10 option at the position I'll be it if
we're taking them out of the top five I
won't completely disagree with you there
now just in time nice Christian Kirk
time to panic so I would just say this
Jaguars offense unfortunately Trevor
Lawrence is not looking like the same
world beater just overall that he looked
like in weeks two and three and that's
the problem here because we have
Christian Kirk not exactly completely
pulling away from everyone maybe he is
financially but we do have Zay Jones
Evan Ingram even Marvin Jones factoring
heavily into the passing game during any
during any given week and unfortunately
what Trevor Lawrence overall on the
season you know pff's 28th highest
graded passer among 35 qualified
quarterbacks his yards per attempt are
down we just haven't seen Trevor
Lawrence be consistent enough for his
number one wide receiver to be the same
so I saw Christian Kirk as a top 24 wide
receiver and four PPR scoring this week
I think he's going to settle in as more
as a you know borderline wide receiver
too as opposed to top 12 options so
another similar sentiment to like Kyle
Pitts like it sucks that we can't be
higher on Christian Kirk but still a
quality guy that should be started in
Far More fantasy lineups than not and
from s Browning Travis etm breakout you
guys are just setting me up so well with
these transitions let's go into our
running backs here and starting off with
the rb37 himself Travis etm I'm feeling
good about etn guys and it's both
because of his uh upward trajectory in
terms of his usage yes it has been a
little bit game script and induced you
know you look at Weeks two and three
beat down on the Colts in another
position where they were able to
surprisingly get up on the Chargers to
the extent that James Robinson was able
to go out there make everyone think he
was the locked in rb1 and to his credit
you know he ripped off to 37 to 51-yard
touchdowns and he looked you know good
out there obviously a great story coming
back from the Achilles but when you look
at the whole season our full five game
sample size
Travis etn has been the better running
back guys and you can look at anything
you want you can look at our PFF grades
etn68.4 James Robinson 62.5
maybe you're not a fan of PFF I wish you
were but if you aren't fine your eyes
per carry etn 4.9 James Robinson 4.1
yards after contact for Kerry guess who
has more Travis etn who's forcing more
missed tackles for Kerry Travis etn
yards per outrun 1.36 versus 0.58 yards
per reception 11.3 versus 5.6 I don't
like taking away the players big plays
they earned those plays they happened I
it's it's annoying to me but if you guys
have lost the Jaguars games you saw the
fourth and one touchdown Robinson had
against the Chargers like anybody could
have run through that hole and gotten
those 50 yards if you take away those
wide open touchdown runs that James
Robinson has had this year 2.97 yards
per carry now is that a factor of the
offense absolutely this Jaguars offense
hasn't looked as good over the last two
weeks as they did uh during the first
three of the season but that's another
Factor that's going to help Travis CTN
because he out snaps James Robinson when
they are playing from behind which all
of a sudden is looking more and more
likely for this 2022 versions of the Jag
wires offense so with that let's get our
Panic meter
[Music]
here with etn relative to our preseason
expectations obviously James Robinson
isn't going anywhere and with his
Jaguars offense it can still seemingly
go either way with them being either
really good or really bad but just with
the etn he looks great out there which
coming off the list Frank injury really
we couldn't assume going into this year
and at a minimum we do have an explosive
pass catching back involved in a two
running back committee so that's a big
thing here at the utn I'm not saying you
can go out there on a weekly basis and
fire him up as his top 20 option that
you dropped into B and that's why we are
in a yellow stage of panic I mean he's
not the guy that we drafted him to be
and that's not necessarily going to
change anytime soon with that said in
full PPR you're gonna have an awfully
hard time ranking more than 30 running
backs ahead of them during any given
week he's still a solid Flex option and
guys God forbid something happens to
James Robinson all of a sudden we could
be talking about Travis etn as a weekly
top 12 option look at guys like romante
Stevenson look at Kenneth Walker you
guys see what happens when one injury
happens to these two running back
backfields that's what's so big so it's
a new game these days guys we can't
expect every running back to have a
Workhorse role in the year 2000 I
believe it was 19 different running
backs had at least 300 touches last
season there were four so when guys like
Travis etn you know guys like even cam
makers over there in Los Angeles it's
disappointing we can't use them the way
we thought we're going to use them but
it still is a two running back committee
and I know it sucks that you used a
fourth round pick you know on a premier
handcuff that's only giving you a little
bit of flex value but again that's a
very valuable fantasy asset even if you
unfortunately had to overpay to get them
a few months ago
from LA City Zeke or Kenneth Walker this
week absolutely Kenneth Walker and it's
probably gonna be Kenneth Walker the
rest of the season taking us right here
into our next running back Ezekiel
Elliott just the RB 38 on the year and
similar to a lot of these players it's
not just Zeke's fault football is
obviously a team sport and hey guys I'm
a Columbus Ohio lifer if anyone should
try to spew you you know some
Shenanigans about Zeke being fine and
it's just been the offense's fault it
would be me but we got a lot of red
flags going on right here and first of
all it's just the reality that this
cowboys offense isn't nearly as good as
last season and it's not just because
having Cooper Rush under Center instead
of Dak Prescott 24th in scoring this
year pff's 27th ranked offensive line in
run blocking there's a lot of problems
going on and also they're starting to
affect Ezekiel Elliott we talked about
George Kittle and kind of that fallacy
around the idea that he's now this left
tackle Ezekiel Elliott might as well be
the left tackle in this conversation
guys he is only on Pace to catch 17
passes in 17 games 17 catches and 17
games his previous career low is 26
receptions in 2017 but that was when he
was suspended and he only played 10
games so really they're either leaving
him in the pass block or they'll throw
in the football Tony Pollard who is
averaging a full 1.8 rushing yards more
than Ezekiel Elliott this season so no I
don't think the Cowboys are going to
turn the backfield over to Tony pauler
they're too proud and to be fair like I
think Ezekiel Elliott his ability to
just get the short yard is get the tough
yards pass block he still does a lot of
really important things he just doesn't
do them at a high enough level to kind
of Warrant that 90 million dollar
contract what running back does warrant
a 90 million dollar contract some might
ask and that's a pretty fair question so
a lot of problems going into Ezekiel
Elliott and with that we go to our Panic
meter
foreign
[Music]
it's red again it's one of these things
where what happened with the Cowboys
offense when Dak was under Center they
looked absolutely terrible for the first
50 minutes of that game just because a
Dack absolutely not it was because they
had one wide receiver out there and they
had a banged up offensive line not doing
them any favors so as much as Michael
Gallup has come back and looked good I
just don't think we're looking at the
same top five scoring offense in Dallas
that we thought we were before the
season this is a defensive minded team
of Michael Parsons emerging as one of
the best players in the NFL and even if
the Cowboys are willing to give Zeke 15
to 20 carries per game I just think he's
he's even behind guys like Damien Pearce
and Dave Montgomery in terms of his
overall usage with how involved Tony
Pollard is so Tony Pollard ceases to
exist okay something could happen with
Zeke not telling you guys to cut him you
know I still do think there could be
slightly better it is ahead but I think
that coming back it's gonna get Zeke
more so into the low end rb2 borderline
rb2 conversation the days of looking at
Ezekiel Elliott as a locked in top 12
rb1 are over
from Jimmy Jam in the chat are we buying
Alan Robinson no we are not buying Alan
Robinson let's talk about just how much
we should be panicking about the Rams
alleged wide receiver too so the big
thing to remember with Alan Robinson
it's not that he's been bad he has
arguably been the worst wide receiver in
the entire NFL among the guys that have
gotten the opportunity to go out there
on the field so on the season PFF
receiving grade it's been 84 wide
receivers with at least 15 targets Al
Robinson ranks 83rd yards per outrun
83rd yours per reception 78th targets
per outrun dead last nobody has earned
targets at a lower rate on their routes
than Alan Robinson this season and yeah
you know we can go back to August we can
read all the fluff pieces about how his
you know route running is going to be so
utilized by Sean McVay and Matthew
Stafford loves having him out there
we're still waiting to see it guys and
so far through five weeks only Chase
Claypool is averaging fewer yards per
Target now in Robinson under 25 yards
and four or five games this season again
25 yards it's not that he's been
relatively bad we're talking about the
wide receiver 76. this has been unusable
bad in an offense that we talked about
there's so many problems going on that
no I don't think Alan Robinson is the
worst wide receiver in the NFL certainly
doesn't look good though and then when
you out on the fact that oh this
offensive line is terrible oh Matthew
Stafford isn't playing good and oh
Matthew Stafford literally guys targets
Cooper cup and Tyler Higby at a higher
rate than any other pair of teammates in
the NFL so I know that's that you know
what Cooper and Higby it's a little bit
like the Kobe Bryant and Kwame Brown you
know combining for 81 points or whatever
but seriously Tyler and Hickman is
getting force-fed the ball too that's
why he's the tight end six on the season
so we have Cooper cup we have Tyler
Higby I remain just a little bit hopeful
in cam makers eventually taking over
this backfield otherwise guys though no
not feeling good about Alan Robinson and
I'll show you how much I don't feel good
about him bring up the Panic meter
foreign
I got eight players for you guys and a
Rob is the only one in dark red I said
last week on the PFF fantasy football
podcast that more shallow leagues could
cut him he does not need to be someone
you're keeping through the buy it could
only get worse for him honestly because
we look at this and obj is expected to
come back in November maybe to the Rams
maybe not van Jefferson is someone too
that hasn't played in this offense
throughout the season he could come off
IR at some point and God forbid
something happens to Matthew Stafford
one of the worst backup quarterback
situations in the league over there in
LA so unfortunately Alan Robinson he's
been bad with his volume he's not
getting any volume and I just don't see
any reason to expect either of those
factors to change in a meaningful way
anytime soon from Ray FFA DJ Moore is
killing me help yeah man he's killing
all of us and let's talk about it here
with the Panthers number one wide
receiver but just the watch receiver 49
in fantasy this season so overall PPR
wide receiver 58 29 94 29 and 39
finishes on the year the problem guys is
that DJ Moore he's not getting enough
opportunity to make up for the brutal
efficiency that this offense has brought
out in him I would never call DJ Moore a
bad receiver we've all seen way too much
evidence to suggest that he is the
opposite of that but when you have a
good receiver and a bad offense with a
terrible quarterback that's not throwing
the ball very much you know now all of a
sudden that talent doesn't have many
opportunities to win out in the first
place so in Carolina DJ Moore yeah he
has a team-high 37 targets Christian
McCaffrey's at 35 right behind him and
oh Robbie Anderson out 27 right there as
well
would you guys have guessed that Robbie
Anderson actually leads the Panthers in
receiving yards because he does not dj
Moore and again it comes down to the
fact that it's not even that surprising
that DJ Moore hasn't put up better
numbers if you look at his workload at
PFF we have some expected fancy points
data all it does is just look at the
exact targets the guys got downfield End
Zone they take away what actually
happens so we can just basically see
what the workloads of all these guys are
and DJ more is only the wide receiver 40
and expected PPR points per game so yeah
that's better than the wide receiver 49
right there I don't hate buying low on
DJ Moore because we can look at him as
someone that hey when's the value you're
going to get any lower than it is right
now I'm just not all that certain that
we're going to see him actually boom off
two top 24 Heights and to be fair you
know I'm throwing Alan Robinson under
the bus a lot because of some of his
again terrible efficiency measures and
it is a two-way street trying to throw
and catch the ball DJ Moore is also
popping up in some of these horrendous
metrics so this year the only guys worse
than DJ more in terms of yards per
Target Chase Claypool Allen Robinson and
Hunter Renford has been dealing with a
bunch of injuries so let's go to our
Panic meter
[Music]
on DJ not quite as bad as Alan Robinson
but it's just the reality that right now
we have an injured version of Baker
Mayfield guessing that's not going to be
better than the non-injured version of
Baker Mayfield God bless PJ Walker I'm a
huge XFL fan I watched every single snap
that dude took there's a reason why he
was in the xfo and not the NFL and now
the main coach his former head coach at
Temple that got him into the NFL in the
first place no longer there to help
guide him guys like what we're praying
that Sam Donald comes back healthy
that's the point we've gotten to with
the DJ Moore era it's just unfortunately
not an efficient enough offense and it's
too crowded for DJ Moore to bust out in
that when we look at these other bad
passing games Brandon Cooks in Houston
CD lamb in Dallas why are they
overcoming it because they're complete
Target Hogs that has not been the case
for DJ Moore this year again I'm not
putting most of the blame on him I'm
putting it on the offensive environment
the coach is the quarterback
unfortunately those things all matter
when we're trying to look at DJ Moore's
fantasy production I am not expecting
things to get better for him in a
meaningful way anytime soon so that was
our Panic or relaxed segment appreciate
you guys as always now we're getting
some personalized fantasy advice let's
jump into personalized fantasy advice
presented by State Farm where the
personal price plan is all about
creating a price just for you
from Kelly Jacoby Myers or Jalen waddle
gotta still be Jalen Waldo for me
especially with the fact that Tyree kill
not 100 with that foot injury uh pro
football talk did report on Sunday that
tyreik is tentatively expecting to play
through the pain and still be out there
this week but with Jalen waddle guys
it's not so much a bet on you know if
this offense is going to be fantastic
with Skylar Thompson under center it's a
bet on Jalen waddle being a freak is
talent in his own right and Mike
McDaniel their head coach just doing a
good job getting him the ball in easy
ways the Dolphins use more pre-snap
motion than any team in the league top
three and play action I think waddle is
too good with again a coach that knows
how to get him the ball to Warrant
putting on the bench but Kobe Myers in
full PPR still a viable wide receiver
three
from simdog mostert Singletary or AJ
Dylan that's gonna be a close one I do
lean just barely towards AJ Dillon still
this week now we have seen the usage
going a little bit sideways again I have
all three of these guys ranked fairly
close to together I feel a lot better
about Rahim moster if he didn't miss
practice on Wednesday with this new
injury so moster did come out and say
he's going to be out there but
ultimately we have AJ Dylan as a
touchdown favorite at home against the
Jets I mean if this isn't the week to
really Target him and expect it to
happen when will it happen for AJ Dylan
from Eagles fan should I worry about
Aaron Jones I don't think so if anything
AJ Dylan would be the guy to worry more
about because the Jones usage has been
increasing on a week-to-week basis and
guys just in terms of the best overall
running backs this year Jones should be
in anyone's top five every week I tweet
out this chart that on the x-axis it has
you know yards out to contact will carry
on the why it has missed tackle Sports
per carry just two independent
situations where you can look at running
back performance without offensive lines
or quarterback back and stuff like that
we got Nick Chubb absolutely balling out
like he does every year Josh Jacobs
fantastic Talent this year Aaron Jones
is going to be your next special running
back in terms of those two factors so we
know how great he is as a receiver still
don't think we've seen the best version
of this Packers offense Aaron Jones and
AJ Dylan I still believe are going to be
consistent top 20 fantasy running backs
more weeks than not will Jones really
give us that you know Super Sky High
album Kamara Christian McCaffrey as
ceiling that would probably be a no for
me but still someone that you're going
to like to have in your fantasy lineups
far more weeks than not
from kpat 12. three QBs you want to
stream next week yeah guys I know you
might not have that many problems this
week on the Buys in terms of the
quarterbacks because the teams on buys
you know we just weren't using all that
much anyway with all due respect to
Jared Goff but next week we got the
bills the Vikings the Eagles and the
Rams all on bye week so a couple
reasonable options if you want to get
ahead of the game and cover that up
first of all Kenny Pickett going up
against the Dolphins defense that has
been bad period bottom five defense in
pretty much any passing metric you want
to look at and they're banged up Byron
Jones their number one cornerback hasn't
you know it'll come back off the pupless
all season long and Mike McDaniel even
confirmed his recovery from that
Achilles injury is not going as planned
so not expecting Byron Jones back
anytime soon Xavian Howard has been out
there not really doing well and now he's
trying to play through a groin injury so
when you have your starting two
cornerbacks both banged up I don't like
their chances of hanging with George
Pickens and Deontay Johnson all that
well so Kenny Pickett yeah not been the
best so far we have seen those four
interceptions maybe only one of them
really his fault but I do think we've
seen him given his great wide receivers
a chance to go make some plays hopefully
Tua is back by then and we can see a
sneaky shootout of sorts I would also
point out that Daniel Jones and Marcus
Mariota guys are on Pace to post top
five numbers at the quarterback
positions in terms of total Rush
attempts you look at Daniel Jones versus
Jacksonville Marcus Mariota out the
Bengals again two more matchups where
wouldn't be the most surprise to see a
potential sneaky shootout uh emerge and
violate Jameis Winston facing the
Cardinals on Thursday Night Football
assuming he and some of his receivers
are a bit healthier
from Co Juju Rondo or Hearst and the
flex Ron Dale Moore guys gotta go to it
again you look at this Seattle Seahawks
defense they haven't been terrible
against the pass overall but
specifically against wide receivers in
the slot this is the matchup we want to
get going on rondale we couldn't trust
them last week because we didn't know if
he was going to completely displace Greg
Deutsch across the top of the death
chart he did and again the Seahawks
defense 31st and yards per attempt
allowed to wide receivers line to help
out of the slot 32nd passing touchdown
made out loud 30 second explosive pass
play rate allowed 31st and QB rating
allowed so Rondell Moore 100 B HUD is
Mike Williams a week to week must start
yeah we call him a boomer bus wide
receiver guys Mike Lawrence has been a
boomer Boomer Boomer boom or bus wide
receiver this years he's like the only
wide receiver where he has a bad game we
just immediately jump on top of it and
we say yeah take away all the great
games and what do you have well you're
taking away a lot of great games to kind
of make your ill-advised point in the
first place so if Keenan Allen is back
in the picture this week it's not going
to be completely ideal we do know we're
not going to have quite as high as a
Target ceiling but Mike boring is one of
those guys man you just got to live with
the booms and under you gotta excuse me
live with the seldom bust here and there
and accept that he's going to Boom more
times than not they gave him that 60
million contract over this off season
for a reason even if you don't love Mike
Williams just love Justin Herbert's
number one or number two wide receiver
maybe that'll help you look at it
from Rahul Mooney or Curtis Samuel in
the flex I'm still going to go with
Curtis Samuel here it's just more of a
factor of volume here Darnell Millie's
been playing great though it's not
helping us as much in fantasy but that
one-handed obj snag last week hit
another diving catch down field uh two
weeks ago and lastly could have honestly
been a lot bigger two different
opportunities for touchdowns
unfortunately couldn't quite get a
better ball from Justin Fields so really
the talent still very much a great wide
receiver in my opinion but yeah Curtis
Samuel just getting force fed Targets in
those low average Target death areas of
the field just gives him a far higher
week-to-week floor especially in full
PPR from TV Dobbins or Brian Robinson to
start this week ah it's a tough one I'm
gonna lean towards JK Dobbins just as
more basically I think both these
backfields are going to continue to have
three running backs involved we've seen
this in Washington where last week guess
who had the most snaps not Gibson not
Brian Robinson it was JD mckissick which
happens every single time Washington
starts to Trail in a game but there's
three running backs involved not just
one not just too unfortunately that's
the case in Baltimore as well so I
really see Robinson and Dobbins having a
pretty equal carry uh you know just
alignment with each other and then at
that point we want the Baltimore Ravens
offense or the Washington commanders
offense I will take the Ravens
would I trade Jeff Wilson from Mari
Cooper yes Jets great trade I would do
that the thing with Jeff Lawson he's
been doing well with his touches but
Tyrion Davis price back at practice this
week Kyle Shanahan longtime BFF Kevin
Coleman already starting to eat into
that workload and unfortunately in San
Francisco they're tied with the Ravens
and dead last in terms of targets to
their running back we're not getting
those we're always going to have Kyle
just check doing Kyle juice check things
Depot Samuel's gonna do Debo Samuel
things so we really need one running
back in San Francisco in order to be
expecting anything resembling you know
consistent fantasy production and don't
forget Elijah Mitchell on IR with that
knee injury not a given he's gonna be
out for the entire season so awesome
chance to go trade Jeff Wilson for
someone in Amari Cooper that hey would
you Cody present leading this top 10
ranked scoring offense we've already
gotten some nice booms from Mari Cooper
I think Wilson versus Mari Cooper is a
fairly reasonable uh you know start sit
dilemma during any given week right now
guys what's the Sean Watson back is down
the stretch for the fantasy playoffs
it's not even going to be close Amari
Cooper is going to be a weekly must
start at that point who even knows if
Jeff Wilson is still going to be the rb1
in San Francisco
from J mob should I be scared about
James Connor you shouldn't be thrilled
about James Connor he's out for at least
this week does seem like it could be a
multi-week injury it didn't put him on
IR which is good so we're not expecting
him to be missing you know boatloads of
time but yeah it's not great to have
this running back with a long injury
history now be experiencing another
injury hope you were able to go get you
know Benjamin in the meantime
and last one everybody classic JP mixin
or Deontay Johnson or just Panic yeah I
think I think a good going with Joe
Mixon again he leads the NFL in touches
he's been the rb15 in PPR points per
game that sucks he drafted him as a top
10 running back not a top 15 uh you know
dropping the B of the rb15 but think
about that that's really pretty much his
floor with this usage that he is able to
get this year so unfortunately it's 047
on Rush attempts inside the five yard
line trying to convert those in the
touchdowns we did see him last week
finally start getting some room to run
you're notice for Kerry not the most you
know predictive stat and just I
understand it's more of an offensive
stat than a specific running back but
over five last week expecting bigger and
better things out of this Bengals
offense and again the usage is there for
a player that we still know is good I am
not panicking on Joe Mixon or Deontay
Johnson for that matter with Deontay
this year no touchdowns yet only 53 and
a half yards per game guys I had never
been more confident that deante Johnson
is an elite receiver every week on
Monday night I post an article my
shishapur I go through all the nullified
touchdowns you know the guys that were
open and got a bad pass or the guys that
dropped the touchdown Deontay Johnson is
on this list every single week usually
multiple occasions and yeah we have had
a couple drops here and there but more
than anything it's him using that
incredible route running ability getting
open unfortunately dealing a bit too
much of the trubisky and young Kenny
pick experience with that said follow
that volume follow that Talent Buy Low
on deante Johnson
guys that's gonna wrap it up here
another edition of BR fantasy again this
has been presented by State Farm always
love those guys and love you guys for
tuning in with us each and every week go
out there get that W in week six we'll
be right back here in week seven until
then take care everybody
foreign